lebron james on receiving nfl interest
during the
nba lockout in 2011. yes there was an
nba lockout on top of the nfl
lockout but the nfl was back and the nba
was in flux
and lebron james says i would have made
the team one thing about it i don't mind
working for something so i would have
had to try out for the cowboys of the
seahawks or if i'd stayed home and went
back home to cleveland
i'd have tried out but i would have made
the team i just know what i'm capable of
doing on the football field especially
at that age 10 years ago
a large human being who would have been
an excellent tight end
i think he did the right thing by
sticking with the nba
but i don't i don't doubt i don't doubt
that that they just
the size the the you know the body
shape everything about i mean he would
have been a great football player
i don't know how long he would have
lasted the nfl physically but he would
have been a great football player i'm
convinced of that
yeah and you look at all the players in
the past mike that cowboys have had who
played
other sports you look at bob hayes was
the fastest man ever
you know 100 uh in the olympics and
they've tried a whole bunch of guys they
even drafted carl lewis one year and so
it would have made perfect sense if
lebron was going to
go play football that he would play for
the cowboys who by the way or his
favorite team
and i think it would have been a great i
look back on the cowboys in 2011 who
their tight ends were of course they had
jason witten who was still in the prime
of his career at that point they had
martellus bennett and they had john
phillips so he certainly could have made
the rosters at least their third tied in
and they'd have found a role for him for
sure but i have no doubts mike that he
could have played in the nfl and been a
really good football player
he was 26 at the time he played receiver
in high school
much more filled out though as a grown
man than he was
in high school like we see so many of
the nba players do they get thicker and
thicker
football players as well i remember how
skinny vince young was
when i first saw him playing for texas
and he was anything but as he got deeper
and deeper in his nfl career
um i the
the reality though is it seems like
most football players would love to play
in the nba
but few nba players would love to play
in the nfl
i think that well the the pa what do we
do every july when nba free agency
happens
we marvel at the contracts being given
to guys
we've never heard of right i mean i
don't follow basketball closely enough
and even then the people who do follow
like who the hell is that getting 20
million a year
so when you only have five guys on the
floor and you play 82 games
and you have a tv contract that espn
put way too much money into you get a
ton of money for nba players and you
know
randy moss would have loved to play in
the nba terrell owens would have loved
to play in the nba
it just shows you how rare the skill
sets are
to be highly effective nba players
and lebron james the king of that
mountain at least current down i don't
want to get into the whole lebron
michael jordan thing
but uh yeah he would have been selling
his talent short if he had played
football i say that
as an ardent supporter of the sport but
i recognize
that the guys who would be the best
basketball players should not be
messing around with football it's
amazing mike when you go into nfl locker
room that's all they want to talk about
is the nba
i mean dez bryant was the biggest nba
fan of all time but
all of them they follow the nba they
debate the nba
that's all they want to talk about and
they would have loved if they could have
done it to have been basketball players
i guarantee you
you get to play more games you make more
money you have longer careers i mean
what's not to like about that and so a
lot of those players in the nfl would
have loved to have gone and played
basketball i'm with you there are very
few nba players that say
i wish i was playing in the nfl but
lebron is one that i have
full uh confidence could have been good
at whatever sport he tried
having said that michael jordan wasn't a
great baseball player but i think lebron
could at least done football
and i think if michael jordan had done
baseball from the get-go
and stuck with him yeah maybe you know
kind of like tim tebow maybe just maybe
but but hey
it's i say the same thing about baseball
if you got a great football player who
could be
a major league baseball player i i take
bait kylie murray
you play baseball a lot longer now kyle
murray may make more money playing
football if he
gets a franchise quarterback contract
but uh
my my son nephew brother
friend anyone yeah all things equal
i'd say play baseball professionally
over football because you will play
longer
you'll be healthier on the back end and
there's a good chance you'll make far
more money look at remember jeff semarja
he would have been a first round
receiver
10 12 years ago uh he made he made
we did the the math at one point he made
more than calvin johnson
in uh in his baseball career maybe
significantly more than calvin johnson
in his baseball career and doesn't have
the health issues
that push calvin johnson out of the
sport after only nine seasons
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports